about what is a factorial well you can
see this exclamation point here or what
looks like an exclamation point and what
that is that's a factorial and it
doesn't really mean like you know yay 3
right it means you take this number 3
and you multiply down to one so for
example 3 factorial is actually 3 times
2 times 1 which equals 6 let's look at
another example 1 factorial
well this one's already at 1 so for
multiplying down to one it's just going
to be 1 now 0 factorial this is one
you're gonna have to memorize but 0
factorial just equals 1 okay so this one
memorized a lot of times students make a
mistake of thinking it's 0 but it's
actually 1 and then 6 factorial same
thing you would start at 6 and you would
multiply down to 1 so this would be 6
times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
let's see that comes out to 720 okay and
then the last one here this is a common
mistake that I want you to avoid 2
factorial times 3 factorial does not
equal 6 factorial you have to actually
simplify these individually so 2
factorial is 2 times 1 3 factorial is 3
times 2 times 1 so you can see this is
going to be 12 okay and that's your
answer so let's get into the examples
here number one you can see we've got 8
factorial divided by 6 factorial how
would we slip simplify that one well 8
factorial is 8 times 7 times 6 all the
way down to 1 but what I'm going to do
here is I'm just going to stop once I
get to 6 factorial and the reason is is
this it just represents 6 5 4 3 2 1
but the reason I stopped there is
because you can see that the 6 factorial
in the numerator is cancelling with the
6 factorial in the denominator now you
just have to simplify 8 times 7 which
gives us 56 and you got it okay let's go
to example number 2 so this one we've
got 3 factorial times 7 factorial
divided by 6 factorial times 4 factorial
okay so let's see if we can analyze this
one so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to leave this as 3 factorial 7
factor I'm going to write as 7 times 6
factorial and then the 6 spectrum and
leave it that one as it is and then 4
factorial I'm gonna write as 4 times 3
to 1 that's 3 factorial right and the
reason I did that is you see how the 3
factorial
the denominator is cancelling with the
three factorial in the numerator and
same thing with the sixes right so we're
really just left with seven over four
and you've got it now how did I know you
know to do it in that manner well what
you can do is you can look at one that's
larger right see 4 is larger than 3 so
what I did is I took 4 and I went until
I get down to 3 then I knew I was going
to have a match I'd be able to cancel
same thing here at 7 factorial I went 7
6 factorial and then I knew that the
sixes were going to cancel so again
you'd start with the larger one and then
count down you know by one at a time
okay let's go to number three now so
this one is more of a you know variable
expression we've got n plus 3 the
quantity factorial over N factorial now
let me ask you a question which one do
you think is larger the numerator or the
denominator okay if you said the
numerator you're absolutely right
because you can see this is 3 more than
n the word is this is just n right so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna start
with that larger one that larger
quantity n plus 3 and we're going to
multiply down and plus 2 and n plus 1
and n factorial right so you can see I
keep subtracting 1 each time just like
when I went over here we've got 3
factorial n 3 and then 3 minus 1 is 2
and the 2 minus 1 is 1 it keep going
down by 1 so that's what I'm doing here
just subtracting 1 each time until I've
got a match with the numerator and the
denominator this way I can cancel those
and we're just left this with this
quantity right here and you can foil
that out and multiply it out on your own
ok and then number 4 the last one we've
got 3 n plus 2 the quantity factorial +
3 n minus 1 the quantity factorial right
so which one do you think is larger in
this case the numerator or the
denominator
well again the numerator is larger in
this one because you can see that this
is n plus 2 this is 3 and minus 1 so
this is this is definitely larger so
we're going to take that larger one and
we're going to count down okay so 3 n
plus 2 3 n plus 1 I just keep
subtracting 1 each time 3 n 3 and minus
1 factorial and now you can see we've
got to match with the numerator in the
denominator these are going to cancel
and we're just left with this expression
here and again you can foil that out if
you like or you can